sis  and ineos grenadiers have worked  together for five seasons now  i've seen a big step forward over them  five years  for me what's the nicest thing is  working with a company like sis  it's not just a case of there's your  product off you go good luck  it's really a relationship where we work  and bounce  and take them steps together if there's  a product that  we feel is missing we can approach sis  tell them help create it and  that product will end up benefiting both  of us and that's quite rare with the  sponsor so for me that's one of the  nicest things is that  we can bounce off each other and and  create ideas and great products and  you know the end result being i feel  like we're out there on the road with  the best stuff available to any cycling  team and and we've got it  you